in the previous update we started to
build the roof of our sketchy room
[Music]
we were a bit in a hurry because the
rainy season is almost here not only to
protect the interior of the ruin but
also because working under the rain is
annoying and a bit dangerous we are
determined to finish it this week so
there is no time to lose welcome to a
new parade Camp update
[Music]
new day back on the roof again
still there
the roof's still there
no collapse yet
uh
the foil is in place
we sealed it put some tape
it's water tight
hopefully airtight
we got to rain last night and no leaks
inside that's a good thing yeah great
uh the counter buttons are on
and now we are going to put the battens
in place
so the roof is ready for tiling the
working width of the roof tiles is uh 22
and a half centimeters the roof is four
meters wide we're going to have a little
bit of overhang on both sides so four
meters divided by 22 and a half is 18 so
if we have 19 roof tiles times 22 and a
half
gives us 4 meter 28 and that would mean
like 14 centimeters of overhang on both
sides we are going to make the patterns
this long
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now that all the patterns are in place
we've pulled a rope to Mark the future
edge of our roof uh we Mark the patterns
and now we're going to cut them with the
circular saw
ready
there's the power
yeah you have to get another one all
right guys we're trying to make a movie
here silence on the set hey joking
joking and the music
yeah the roof dials stick over the wall
by 15 centimeters
but
to finish the roof off nicely
we are going to have red cedar boards
running all along the sides so by itself
it will already last like 25 years
outside but we want to expand this life
so I'm oiling so you go with the grain
make long holes with the grain a little
cloudy here and a little smooshy Cloud
there
and that's how you paint the board
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so this should be the angle
for our roof
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what you doing over there I'm reading
around the base of the trees
making a little berm so the water
stays at the roots got it yeah put a
little river mud right yeah
prepare your board
all right oh
so here we are we are breaking down the
house into town we got the offer from a
neighbor to reuse their tiles so we're
gonna help them to take down these tires
bring them back to our room where we
would reuse them again good tiles a
little bit thicker
a bit dirty but nothing that we cannot
clean
ers
okay
oh boys
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we always try to reuse as much as we can
in addition to the touch we got from the
neighbor we also kept the original one
from the ruin
we store them around and now we are
taking them back on the roof
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right
can you take off your hat no then the
sun's blinding me so much
oh it's my shadow in your face yeah it
needs some shadow in my face you cannot
have the full song
what do you want maybe look this way huh
like that way
okay
all right
today is an exciting day
guys
silence
silence on the set please the roof is
ready for tiling now it's exciting day
it's also going to be a long day because
we want to finish the roof today before
the rain comes
that's why we've got our friends to help
us
[Music]
know
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I'm cutting tiles into the
corners into the
um angle part of the roof
and try to fit them in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
once this is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
boys doing well mate doing a bit of
grinding any problems no problem many
different kind of tiles let's see how
they fit together
yeah is that a challenge
uh challenge at least
we are mixing the odd ones in with the
one ones we have most
I think it works okay
looks pretty good we'll see
eight different types of tiles yeah for
that side of the roof eh okay
foreign
we should already have half ones right
there
foreign
foreign
[Music]
this side is almost finished
we kept finding so many broken tiles in
the stacks
let's call Adrian let's see if he can
find some yeah
hmm
hey
how's it going
so last time we came with this mother
what part of the roof we got the ties we
put the mic in our drawings then start
to rain so this work need to stop for a
bit so then we still had some tiles to
fairly power in our room so today we
came to finish the job
finally we fill up the car with tiles
and now we go back to camp
[Music]
now that we have some extra tires we can
get up and get the job done
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah I will do the job
[Music]
not super happy with it
first time I'm doing something like this
got a bit messy
but
I think it's a water water type
that's what matters putting in the last
tiles
and then
we've got a dry house
Dry house
[Music]
the roof is finished
foreign
ly got our roof ready to protect us from
the rain in Winter and from the Charming
summer
as you might have noticed we have
designed a big overhanging on the south
face of our ruin
this design lets the sunlight enter
through our window in Winter to heat up
the house while in the hottest months of
the year and summer our window will
remain in the shape of keep the space
cooler getting the best of every season
for our sketchery
to get to this design we would use data
obtained from the solar disk that you
can find in our previous update
if you are still interested in getting
more in-depth info about the ruin you
can visit our Richard model following
the link in the description
[Music]
in the next update we will do the
biggest clearing of mimosas we have ever
done and we will share some insights we
got from an expert
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update
and don't forget to subscribe
wait wait wait if you like what we do
support us in patreon to watch the
videos one week ahead